For those who are very creative but high
in neuroticism,
how should one work to gain emotional
stability in order to go out into chaos,
to do more creative things?
That's a really good question.
You know what I learned about that by
reading Young's works on El Camino,
weirdly enough.
And so back again in graduate school
when I was writing,
starting to write maps of meaning and
really tearing myself apart
psychologically.
I'm trying to understand evil,
I suppose the evil of the Cold War and
the evil of the individuals who compose
Nazi Germany in Stalinist,
Russia.
Um,
um,
I,
I was reading Carl Jung because he,
he,
he wrote his tracks on alchemy where a
lot about self transformation and he
talked about,
uh,
it's hard to explain his works on
Alchemy,
but suffice it to say that his advice
was something like,
the advice he derived from the alchemist
was that if you were going to make mess
around with very complicated and
dangerous matters,
that's a good way of putting it.
That you should really put your life
together.
And so I would say the right way to deal
with your neuroticism is to increase
your conscientiousness because we also
know that the higher your
conscientiousness,
the lower your neuroticism
conscientiousness does seem to keep
neuroticism and check.
And so I would say,
and have said this to many people,
I'm clean your room.
Organize your life like get a routine.
Get up everyday at the same time,
go to bed at the same time.
Establish disciplined habits.
And that will help a lot schedule like.
And here's how to use a schedule.
Use a,
use a calendar.
I use Google calendar,
but don't use it as a tyrant.
You know what you want to use your.